ils ont dit que vous l'aviez abandonné quand il était
bébé je n'ai pas abandonné mon enfant il a
50 ans aujourd'hui voici votre femme me dit que vous
pensez que vous êtes légèrement déprimé eh bien j'ai eu
le sac imma j'emploierai oui ce n'était pas de
ta faute était-ce  c'est pourquoi je suis
déprimé c'est Martin Sixsmith
qui était l'homme de la BBC à Moscou Je connais
cette femme, elle a eu un bébé quand elle était
adolescente et elle l'a gardé secret pendant 50
ans ce dont vous parlez serait
ou ils appellent  c'est une histoire d'intérêt humain
c'est je ne fais pas ceux pourquoi pas bonjour
tu dois être Philomène la mère est-ce qu'elle
était diabolique je n'aimais pas ce mot non c'était une
bonne histoire plus sage tu es journaliste
eh bien j'étais Marsh est le
Catholique romain que j'étais autrefois, je
reçois la marge de traitement royal si
vous aimez le champagne ou les boîtes du pape Oh
non merci c'est gratuit oh je dois
tout payer sur ryanair je
veux seulement savoir s'il va bien quoi  est-
il mort au Vietnam que pensez-vous qu'il était
obèse ce qui vous fait penser qu'il serait
obèse à cause de la taille des
portions
et c'est tout ouais sinon comment tu te
souviens de tout ce qu'il a dit bonjour bonjour
bonjour ça devait être salut
je veux juste te parler de mon fils
il m'a été enlevé et je le
cherchais  depuis
pourquoi Dieu nous accorderait-il un
désir sexuel qu'il veut ensuite que nous
résistions, c'est que je ne savais même pas que j'avais un
clitoris Martin vice